in one video he says that whiteness is
not a race but a racial ideology listen
in america as in many other parts of the
western world whiteness is the dominant
racial ideology we think of power in
terms of race whiteness has the most
power the fact that whiteness is the
dominant racialized power structure that
is the problem and that is why we have
to involve race in all of our arguments
and considerations i'm always annoyed
and a bit perplexed by the number of
cuts and edits these tick talkers need
for a one-minute video
there's a cut after every sentence
they're not able to string together two
sentences at once now i speak for an
hour straight on this show with no cuts
at all many of my sentences may be
rambling and unnecessary but at least i
can put multiple sentences together
these people have to cut and think about
the next sentence before filming and
still it ends up being incoherent but
the greater point is that this teacher
is a self-hating white freak subjecting
students to his intellectual masochism